I would like to talk to you about drugs
and I know I know
I already sound like a middle school
health teacher about to show you a video
like this the pattern is generally the
same take a lack of responsibility the
inability to make right choices add to
an ignorant and indifference and top it
off with a desire for escapism and kicks
the sum total is then conceivably found
in the Benny's the Reaper the pop needle
yes the pot needle now you may laugh but
that film worked think about it when was
the last time that you saw a pot neither
exactly exactly
but unfortunately America is now in the
midst of a new drug crisis and it seems
that no one is safe from it Laura
Charlie's owner who asked us not to use
her last name says Charlie had to be
rushed to the vet you can't see the
suspect throw the drugs over the fence
in the video but that's Charlie and what
she's eating is a full bag of heroin you
can't process the fact that your dog ate
heroin yeah and if she can't process it
imagine how it must have felt for her
dog when it kicked in who's a good boy
I'm a good boy I'm a really good boy I'm
the best boy
even that like hotties local news story
had some chilling context Garrett Bishop
runs the bar can play where it happened
he says it highlights a much bigger
problem this whole heroin problem around
here is is ridiculous you know we find
needles we find everything around here
and it's it's getting to the point to
where I can't let my employees go
outside okay that is terrifying although
honestly rampant heroin abuse near a
doggy daycare center is the first case
that McGruff the Crime Dog is actually
qualified to solve well the thing is
that that is symptomatic of the fact
that America is facing an epidemic of
addiction to opioids like heroin and
prescription painkillers as of 2015 an
estimated 2.6 million Americans were
addicted to them and they're now
involved in almost 30,000 overdose
deaths a year in the US and the
prevalence of this problem astonishes
some people just listen to Donald Trump
up in New Hampshire they said the
biggest single problem they have up here
is heroin and I said how does heroin
work with these beautiful lakes and
trees and all of the beautiful it
doesn't yeah it does no it does
heroin works basically everywhere
because it's heroin it's not a cellphone
heroin has full coverage so so tonight
we're going to look at one of the major
causes of this crisis prescription
painkillers which are chemical cousins
of heroin around 75 percent of heroin
users started with a prescription
opioids drugs like oxycontin vicodin and
percocet which some take recreationally
and others takers prescribed by a doctor
but however it starts it can get out of
hand fast so how many if we start from
this side have moved from prescription
drugs to heroin
everybody enjoy so much more cheaper
once people became dependent on
painkillers
they said they do almost anything to get
them one time I I was hurting so bad
that I ended up punching a 4x4 and
breaking all three of these fingers and
this bone to get pain meds from my
doctor I did that several times so you'd
hug yourself in order to go that's like
he pulled out in my head for
descriptions at the time that's how I
get a prescription I live like loops of
people where they take away that to
their wrists protons I mean how many
people do know someone has died of
overdose from everybody this is
happening everywhere
the odds are right now you probably know
someone who is struggling or who has
died from an opioid addiction some towns
have been devastated just two months ago
in and around Huntington West Virginia
28 overdoses occurred in one five-hour
span and given their risks it's kind of
amazing how freely doctors have
prescribed them because there are a lot
in circulation we have currently nearly
250 million prescriptions for opiates
written every year that's enough for
every adult in America to have a bottle
of pills and then some holy
and those bottles aren't necessarily
sitting on a shelf unused like that
bottle of wine that you are saving for a
special occasion but now serves as a
reminder that you haven't had a single
event in four years that was deserving
you're getting fancy drunk
these these pills are getting used or
falling into the hands of others from
from those who are already addicted to
just bored teenagers so how has this
happened because interestingly as
recently as the early 90s doctors were
excessively wary of prescribing opioids
back then there was a thing called OPA
phobia
a lot of health care professionals did
not want to prescribe opiates at all
because they thought you give the
slightest amount you turn your patients
into addicts and so even people with
stage four cancer weren't being giving
obvious they were left to suffer yes
OPA phobia which is not to be confused
with Oprah phobia which is the
irrational fear of screaming talk-show
hosts giving you a brand new
Pontiac sedan Oprah I can't afford the
taxes on this yeah haven't thought it
through
obviously that level of undertreating
pain was a huge problem in itself and to
their credit pain care advocates work to
dispel some dangerous myths but in doing
so they made a key mistake as you will
see right at the end of this clip today
the federal government said in a report
that about half of all surgery patients
suffer needlessly because doctors and
hospitals don't pay enough attention to
painkiller health secretary Louis
Sullivan talked about myths the pain
builds character myth he said that
infants don't feel pain another myth
that elderly patients have a higher
tolerance for pain or that painkillers
are addictive all myths ok ok ok
first of course babies feel pain how the
did we ever think otherwise but
more importantly the fact that
painkillers are addictive was not a myth
it's like a book of Greek mythology
featuring the stories of Zeus
Sisyphus Oedipus and Yanni come on that
last one is very real and it cannot be
dismissed and look a nuanced discussion
between the medical community about the
complexities of pain treatment is
clearly important the problem is that
discussion became dominated by the
pharmaceutical industry who started
amplifying the message that opioids
should not just be used for acute pain
like that from cancer or surgery but for
all sorts of pain like arthritis and
back aches which makes sense as a motive
coming from the pharma industry
end-of-life pain care is a narrow
business it's hard to make a lot of
money off of a product exclusively
marketed to people who are close to
death honestly I don't know how Fox News
even does it I have no idea it's a
mystery
poly like
but I don't know and within the pharma
industry the loudest voice was Purdue in
1996 they released the blockbuster drug
oxycontin and they marketed it to
doctors aggressively giving out swag
like a fishing hats swing music CDs
bearing a slogan swing in the right
direction with oxycontin and oxytocin if
you think we didn't get hold of one of
those you have clearly never watched
this show before because yes here he is
and yes he is my new best friend and yes
his name is Harold and I've gotta say
Purdue this is the perfect choice of
mascots because much like a gorilla
oxycontin might seem appealing but if
you're not careful it will tear your
life apart what your Harold yes he will
Purdue also distributed inspirational
videos like I got my life back featuring
seven patients whose lives were turned
around by the magic of oxycontin since
I've been on this new pain medication I
have not missed one day of work and my
boss really appreciates that Lauren is
there every day so I'm able to be very
productive and one of the things that's
really dear to my heart and which I'm
especially excited about is just the
fact that I'm able to spend time with my
grandchildren it's amazing just to be
able to keep up with them and not have
to always constantly tell them grandma
can't bring no
do their screams hurt and grimace back
hurts that's genuinely sweet and is also
a powerful message although I will note
it makes time with your grandkids more
fun could apply to literally any drug
hey kids
grandpa's gonna take you to the park
okay I'm gonna take on the swings I'm
gonna push you real high and then we're
gonna stay up all night I'm gonna come
up with inventions and you're gonna
write them down you can write them down
fast we're having quality time through
stories other platoon video sought to
reassure patients who might have been
nervous about taking such a strong drug
less than 1% of patients taking opioids
actually become addicted less than 1%
and I know it may seem like they are
pulling that number out of their ass but
they actually pulled it out of the
letters to the editor section of the New
England Journal of Medicine seriously
this is it that paragraph is the whole
thing it wasn't peer-reviewed and it was
only about short-term use of opioids in
hospitals but it became the main source
for that 1% claim and letters pages are
not a solid source for information just
this month a Pennsylvania newspaper
published a letter featuring a man's
question about Hillary Clinton's fitness
for office because and I quote what if
that time of the month comes which the
obvious answer is one she's 68 and too
cute maybe
but even if doctors started noticing
that a lot more than 1% of their
patients were getting addicted Purdue
had a ready answer what if they're not
because they had doctors on their
payroll like Alan Spanos who were happy
to explain the helpful new concept of
pseudo addiction I'll let him tell you
about it pseudo addiction is when a
patient is looking like a drug addict
because they're pursuing pain relief so
pseudo addiction is relief seeking
behavior mistaken as drug addiction wow
that is so convenient that is like
Chipotle going have you heard of this
fascinating new thing called pseudo
diarrhea it looks a lot like diarrhea
but it's not diarrhea and the cure may
actually be more tacos and produce
overall message of a quick easy cure for
pain was very appealing especially for
primary care doctors who might only have
15 minutes to treat a patient so it is
no wonder that by the year 2000 doctors
were writing nearly 6 million
oxycontin prescriptions per year and its
sales were more than even viagra and
remember that was a drug that had the
distinct advantage of being sold by Bob
Dole the red-hot late 90s it boy however
evidence started piling up that it was
far riskier than promised with headlines
like oxycontin abuse is increasing and
oxycontin abuse called
a plague or as I'm sure Perdue would
call it a pseudo plague and even the
stars of Purdue's I got my life back
video we're not immune from this trend
because a later investigation discovered
two out of the seven of them died as
active opioid abusers and that
grandmother you saw earlier became
addicted and nearly lost everything
I have lost cause I'd lost I lost a lot
a lot I also want to keep behind taking
that drug when I did lose my dog mm-hmm
and I not lost my medical insurance
although as I said if I was to go to the
mailbox once a month and I would find a
bottle of oxycontin in it I'd probably
still be on it and I'd probably be there
think about losing her health insurance
might have saved her life that is an
irony so deep it would vaporize Alanis
Morissette into a cloud of King Stephen
by now I'm guessing you are pretty angry
at Purdue so you may be glad to hear
that in 2007 they admitted some
responsibility in a lawsuit so big it
actually led to the evening news good
evening
the maker of a hugely popular painkiller
has some pain of its own tonight the
company and its top officers will pay
634 million dollars in fines for lying
to the public Wow
you know they up if they had to
pay over six hundred million dollars for
misleading marketing because you get a
lot of leeway on that
that's why Dunkin Donuts is not yet
being sued for saying America runs on
Dunkin when we all know their real
slogan should be sometimes you can't
find a Starbucks it wasn't just Purdue
pushing the envelope Cephalon paid a
four hundred and forty four million
dollar settlement for over marketing
drugs and insist has been investigated
for some of its practices surrounding a
drug they made containing fentanyl and
opioids which can be a hundred times
more powerful than morphine their drug
is only approved for cancer patients but
interest is accused of not just pushing
it for non cancer patients but even
helping convince insurance companies to
pay for it and to do that according to
one ex-employee they used a particular
shady technique if you don't have cancer
and breakthrough cancer pain no
insurance company is gonna pay for this
medication so if you call up and you
tell them that the patient doesn't have
cancer it's automatically denied someone
said what were you doing they would
always ask does the patient have cancer
uh-huh that's what we would say so you
do uh-huh
you're right say yeah but I'm not saying
yes right I would just say uh-huh
isn't that a yes well that's what they
did think but I wasn't blatantly saying
yes Oh God except everybody knows aha
means yes if you go to thesaurus calm
and type in aha literally the first word
that comes up is yes
followed by options such as absolutely
definitely unquestionably and yep look
and at this point I should say that
Purdue and Cephalon owner told us that
those practices were in the past and
iNSYS has denied wrongdoing and didn't
respond to any of our questions not even
with a na r but at a certain point the
question has to become less what did we
do wrong and more what do we do now
because these drugs are still the most
effective solution for certain types of
pain and many patients need them so we
can't get rid of them but we have to be
much more careful about how they're
prescribed and to their credit the CDC
issued voluntary guidelines this year
suggesting doctors use non-opioid
therapies when possible and if and when
one is needed to start patients with a
lower dose and a sure to supply a
technique that they call start low and
go slow which does sound good but also
sounds like how your creepiest
highschool friends described cunnilingus
start low go slow and afterwards take
her to friendlies chicks love root beer
floats dude they love them dude
no slow low and slow dude those two yeah
what all that sounds great
unfortunately not all areas of the
country have access to alternative pain
treatments it's easy to say use some
non-opioid alternative but in a lot of
rural areas patients don't have access
to things like physical therapy and
mindfulness meditation and insurance
companies won't pay for it and that is a
big problem because even in a rural area
alternative pain treatments should be at
least as easy to find as waffle houses
which like heroin are both hazardous to
your health and dangerously addictive
and to put it mildly it does not seem
that the pharmaceutical industry is
expecting any major reversals in opioid
sales any time soon
in fact they are now marketing extra
drugs to fight one of opioid
side-effects constipation
[Music]
if you need an opioid to manage your
chronic pain you may be so constipated
it feels like everyone can go except you
you know painkillers are powerful if
people use them despite the sound of
this side effect being jealous of a
dog's butthole and that commercial ads
during the Super Bowl this year which
means alley
it is a big business and B I can only
assume there was a reverse commercial
during the Puppy Bowl featuring a
jealous dog and a man but we
cannot just work to prevent future
addicts we're going to need to do more
to help the millions that already exist
which means more investments in
treatment programs as well as increasing
the availability of drugs like the Loch
Lomond naloxone are commonly used in a
nasal spray to rescue people from
overdoses because as this firehouse
makes clear it is a tool that they use
with depressing frequency so every
single firefighter in the Revere Fire
Department knows how to use this has
been trained on this yes has used it yes
from the chief down we tend to have more
overdoses than we do fire fires so it's
a piece of equipment that we can't go
without now just like we have the hose
it's true firefighters might be more
likely to use a nasal spray than our
hose which is really going to cut those
hot firefighter calendars because
something about an overdose reversing
nasal spray isn't quite as sexy it's
still sexy but is not quite as sexy it
is still sexy though just not quite but
still and that's not the point the point
is there is no one simple answer here
not all opioid addicts will respond to
the same treatment and not all people in
pain will find relief from alternative
therapies this is going to take a
massive effort and a significant
investment it won't be cheap it won't be
quick and it won't be easy and it is
hard not to be angry at the drug
companies like Purdue whose promised off
cheap
quick easy pain solutions helped put us
in this mess because while they
may not be solely responsible if you
were to ask me if they bear significant
blame
for reckless greed II behavior which
contributed to this massive public
health crisis I might not say yes
exactly but I would definitely say aha